just a few months ago the international
monetary fund predicted the global
economy would flourish in 2022
but now the imf has a different outlook
thanks to inflation not seen in
decades imf economists said inflation is
the result of pretty much everything
going wrong at the end of 2021
the omicron surge sickening hundreds of
millions of workers worldwide the
resulting production cuts in everything
from oil and gas to consumer goods to
fresh and packaged foods
visitors to this food bank in washington
dc say rising prices are harming their
families
it's really impacted my family
tremendously because if not i wouldn't
be here
you know and and in order for the
organization to help us that's that's
like that's a blessing it's really
nothing in the stores to shop with and
then there's the ongoing global supply
chain disruptions likely to be around
well into 2022
the only way to reverse inflation says
the imf
raise interest rates
monetary policy is at a critical
juncture in most countries
where inflation is broad-based alongside
a strong recovery like in the united
states
or high inflation runs the risk of
becoming entrenched as in some emerging
market and developing economies and
advanced economies
extraordinary monetary policy support
should be withdrawn
in china its zero covet policy is having
an impact on the world's second largest
economy
the report found that less demand for
housing and consumer goods likely will
depress its growth
back in the u.s thanks to a jobs glut
created by the pandemic u.s workers are
demanding and getting bigger paychecks
but the u.s government says consumer
prices also rose seven percent in
december wiping out whatever financial
cushion these workers thought they had
between that and the end of a federal
child tax credit program
low and middle income families are back
to counting every penny sometimes coming
up short so we're having to make some
choices about what people receive in
their bag
we're having to cut down on some of the
the more expensive grains the more
expensive canned items
and substitute those with some that are
a little bit cheaper
enabled the other thing that we're
having to do is figure out what we can
find
we're not able to find as much variety
as we were able to find even last summer
the imf says inflation should go down if
the federal reserve does raise interest
rates this year
that's because people don't spend as
much when credit gets more expensive
it also says economic growth should
improve as more people get vaccinated
and return to work
but if the pandemic worsens again the
imf says inflation will affect all
people's lives for some time to come
rosalind jordan al jazeera washington